if you had a population that approached
the 10th Amendment as if it mattered all
I think the appetite for uh for
dissolving the country we just got to
vote in the right people no no no no no
no no no no the next guy's gonna fix it
you're not going to vote that you're not
going to vote people's opinion into
saying yes I'm I'm pro-stage rights
you're not going to vote that that's
something that I have to be taught to to
kids and something that has to be done
through you know not just school choice
it's got to be like people having more
kids like Tim talks about with like you
know conservatives having more kids
teach ing their kids that's things like
states rights matters like I intend to
be free in my lifetime not in 40 years
I'm not saying that you shouldn't be if
you're saying we gotta wait for the kids
to grow up and teach them all this stuff
and maybe the 10th Amendment it's not
that's too late for me we're gonna be
free very soon and in our lifetime mark
my words